et nous sommes en direct avec laurent
toubiana épidémiologistes chercheur à
l'inserm bonjour et merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france on viens de
l'entendre emmanuel macron qui me promet
donc de nouvelles mesures demain pour
donner de la visibilité pour les
prochaines semaines
au vu de la multiplication de cas est ce
qu'on est selon vous à l'aube de cette
fameuse deuxième vague
non je ne crois pas que nous serions à
l'aube d'une fameuse deuxième vague
je pense au contraire que cette deuxième
vague est une théorie qui n'a jamais été
vérifiée depuis qu'on connaît les
épidémies modernes donc cette espèce de
deux coeurs répandues par un conseil
scientifique en me disant que le nombre
de cas augmente etc etc
depuis des semaines tout ça n'est pas
fondée sur des raisonnements
épidémiologique mais fondée plutôt sur
la sur la peur donc voilà non je ne
crois pas du tout à la à la prochaine
vague épidémique
car si une vague avait pu arriver est
arrivé
comme c'était prévu par les mêmes
personnes
dès la fin du confinement c'est-à-dire
de déconfinement retrouvé à peu près
normalement dans même état que qu'à
l'origine de l'épidémie
c'était cette vague épidémique aurait dû
reprendre
elle n'a pas repris se poser des
questions sur le pourquoi mais il y
aller il ya d'autres réponses que de
dire on a mis en place un confinement et
c'est pour ça que ça s'est bien passé
voilà donc si vous voulez je ne crois
pas à cette seconde vague et je ne crois
pas non plus à l'importance de la
diffusion actuelle du virus
je pourrais dire pourquoi malgré
l'augmentation du nombre de cas de
contamination il ya ce paradoxe un parce
que le chiffre des morts reste faible
les entrées en réanimation baisse
également comment est-ce que vous
l'expliquer est ce que le virus est
aujourd'hui à moins virulent
je ne pense pas que ce soit une question
de virulence du virus c'est simplement
l'histoire naturelle de l'épidémie
d'abord en tombe bien il ne s'agit pas
de nouveau cas il s'agit que nous de
nouveaux individus testés positifs ces
nouveaux individus très positif ne sont
pas des gens malades se sont simplement
des gens qui ont une trace du virus et
7,7 ce nombre de cas on nous le donne
toujours lorsqu'il est important mais
lorsqu'il n'est pas important par
exemple il ya trois jours le nombre le
nombre condamne aujourd'hui c'est 8577
et il ya 3 il y a quatre jours c'était
3287 pourquoi on ne nous a pas donné ce
chiffre là il y a trois jours il était à
1239 pourquoi elle ne nous at on pas
prévenu qu' il n'y avait pas une
croissance exponentielle mais mais au
contraire
la cour avait avait descendu donc vous
voyez
depuis trois semaines on dit la
croissance est exponentielle une
exponentielle ces lecourbe monotone
croissante
elle décroît donc moi j'attends de voir
mais il y à beaucoup d'autres raisons
qui me font dire que le virus ne circule
partent en réalité que 10e
ce test gigantesque fait aller à
l'échelle d'un pays
lorsqu'on test lorsqu'on prend un
échantillon de 7 5 millions de personnes
et dans cet échantillon on obtient 97 %
des gens négatifs 97 % de gens négatifs
pour moi ça veut dire que globalement le
virus ne circule pas s'est même les 3%
restants sont de l'ordre de l'erreur
donc quand vous faites un sondage et que
quelqu'un obtient 97% des suffrages
on vous dit que vous êtes dans une
république bananière eh bien on ne peut
pas vous croire
eh bien là c'est on devrait croire qu'il
y a seulement qu'il y à 97 % de gens qui
ne sont pas positifs et ça c'est une
excellente nouvelle
ce test à l'échelle d'un pays est une
excellente nouvelle parce qu'il nous dit
que le virus en réalité ne circulent pas
est ce que pour vous ce qui est
exponentielle en tout cas aujourd'hui
c'est c'est un fait le nombre de tests
qui ne cesse d'augmenter chaque semaine
et laboratoires aux lois sont débordés
beaucoup de spécialistes s'interrogent
sur l'effet contre-productif de tester
trop de gens est ce que vous en faites
partie garder bon je viens de vous le
dire le nombre de tests comme le
résultat l'est d'ès n'augmente plus
exponentiellement ya eu une sorte
d'épiné ni de volonté d'aller voir des
dalles espère tester parce que les gens
venaient probablement de vacances et ont
juste spontanément envie de savoir s'ils
étaient contaminés voire même
contaminantes encore il faudra le
démontrer mais mais ce nom de test
malgré la citation de la peur qui est
diffusée me plafonne si vous voulez on
n'est plus dans une phase exponentielle
donc même pour ça et de fait je pense
que c'était ce à grande échelle comme ça
ne servent pas à grand chose d'autre qui
a diffusé une forme de désinformation
merci d'avoir pris le temps de répondre
à nos questions laurent et obinna je
rappelle que vous êtes épidémiologistes